le marché du beffroi un lieu que les
élus fn connaissent bien pour y venir
régulièrement
gilles godefroy hélène o'connell deux
élus municipaux à la ville de tours qui
arpentent les allées
ce matin c'est daniel frei zac tête de
liste pour l'indre et loire qui
distribuent les tracts du parti on
compte en vo fait partie des gens qui
perdent un peu espoir sur la france mais
bon c'est comme ça et le vote fn c'est
une solution pour vous je sais pas je
sais pas je tombais souvent sur les gens
comme ça qui font leur colère oui on va
le oui la colère
je veux leur allait l'attendre dans la
population surtout au niveau de la au
niveau de la sécurité des dérives qui a
même dans une ville comme tours qui
paraît calme
c'est ainsi que ça dans les quartiers il
ya vraiment une honte et une montée de
l'insécurité qui est ressenti par la
population et et
un vrai malaise quoi 100% et de chantage
vous allez sentiment que c'est un parti
qui vous est tout ouïe
on est marre d'être des voleurs
tous les autres sont des voleurs on n'a
pas de parent du gouvernement je croyais
pas debout oui vous voyez la jalousie
non j'ai rien à voir j'ai chez moi par
les ménages et pour quoi je parle avec
eux mais alors pas du tout la vérité
vous êtes en droit national
si certains ne se cache plus de leur
préférence pour le vote fn d'autres
persistent a repoussé ce parti bonjour
monsieur je vous en prie bonjour
messieurs dames 1 seul vous empressez
vous le prendre nos fringues photo vous
êtes filmés en plus le front national un
parti qui parvient à mobiliser ses
électeurs
quand la droite et la gauche elle
assiste démunis à la démobilisation de
leur électorat